six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's a lot of people holding today
let's see what's going on with our
caller from the eight to eight area code
caller from eight to eight introduce
yourself tell us what's going on what's
on your mind
hey David my name is Wil I'm from the
North Carolina Tennessee area I'm going
back and forth there right now yeah this
is kind of a more generalized question I
think but I'm I'm a recent college
graduate and I've been trying to
navigate the dangerous waters of online
media and information I guess I was
wondering if you had any advice or
tidbits for looking for new sources or
articles that may be more reliable than
others and or they're just other new
sources that you trust that would be
good starting points fair looking for
information like that
we'll listen couple things number one
and I don't know we're having a I hear
that there's something weird going on
with the phone and people people are
sounding a little bit off and we'll see
if we can fix that there a couple things
number one you need to understand
whether you're looking at a primary
source or not a primary source okay so
you under mo like me when you're reading
an article and all its really doing is
quoting from some other article that is
actually the primary source for a piece
of news I think that step one for any in
a news story is you've got to critically
analyze the primary sources
okay so whether it's originally a story
that's reported by Reuters or Associated
Press or the New York Times or whoever
you want to go to whatever the original
source is to figure out how has this
been how it has the story been put
together once you figure out what are
the facts that are at least being
reported at that point it's sort of up
to you to figure out what type of
analysis are you looking for number one
you want to know if you're looking at a
left wing or a right wing analysis and
you can usually figure that out just by
reading but sometimes what can be tricky
is figuring out what the sort of
financial motives of a particular media
outlet might be so there are websites
like source watch and others that can
explain to you what are the sort of
underlying circumstances or motivations
of any particular news outlet but I
think that the the process for me is
critically analyze the primaries
sources that are originally reporting
then whatever analysts or pundits or
commentators you like go and see what
they are saying and then probably also
look at some opposition media to see
what other points maybe aren't being
considered by by the echo chamber that
we all tend to sort of live in that's
the three-step process I go through okay
and I just really quit any other
resources other than a source watched
like you mentioned that I could use for
just for their detection of information
through somebody's website their
articles you know there are I just don't
know what they what they are offhand so
I wouldn't be able to recommend others
but they are out there for sure thanks
for the call appreciate thank you so
much yeah um whatsoever